welcome back high gas prices are
starting to cause some problems on the
road as joe moeller shows the nevada
freeway service is helping more people
who are trying to make it as far as
possible on
[Music]
empty every trip to the gas station
costing more and more some drivers are
waiting as long as possible before they
have to come back to a gas station but
it appears some drivers are just waiting
too long it can get busy while everyone
is on their daily commutes my route is
i-15. these trucks and the drivers
inside are hard at work i show up at 4
30 and then start at 5. freeway patrol
technician tim stankovic has noticed a
trend lately so we get a lot of people
that run out of gas i already have one
this morning
i had three yesterday now a quarter of
the people he helps a day are out of gas
we were with him tuesday and a short
time after we hopped in his truck white
utility truck southbound south of sarah
we came across his second empty tank
that day at around 8 a.m hey what's
going on
stankovic pulled out the cones the tank
and gave the driver enough to get to a
gas station
george che works in construction i'm out
of the gas i don't make it to the stone
he says he would have been stuck and
admitted getting around is costing him a
lot more 160 a week running out of gas
can cause a problem if somebody stalls
out in the middle of the freeway it's
going to cause
traffic congestion the goal is to keep
people safe and moving people are
struggling and people are trying to make
ends meet sometimes gas is super
expensive right the nevada freeway
service doesn't necessarily respond to
calls they say the first thing you
should do is call the nevada state
police if you find yourself in need of
help on the side of the road stankovic
says the best thing you can do is to
make sure you have enough gas before you
hit the road reporting at decatur 95 joe
mohler live local